horie rivet et président cofondateur de
synopsis qui est fait dans kate
bonsoir monsieur rivet bonsoir monsieur
fillon dit nous quand et comment a été
effectué cette enquête
donc c'est du béton 11 mai on a fait une
enquête auprès de 1000 québécois n'ont
qu'une enquête standard on est
représentatif en termes d'âge sexe
l'ange langues
et puis on ne sont dits dans toutes les
régions du québec également way et donc
qu'ils sont les 10 % de québécois comme
ça qu'ils ont demandé de l'aide
alimentaire
mais ce qui frappe surtout si c'est 10 %
l'homme et c'est le 5 % + ans comme vous
expliquer c'est que la moitié de ces
gens là donc qu au tout 300000 québécois
ont eu recours un comptoir alimentaire
pour la première fois donc c'est comme
si les gens qui ont recours au confort
alimentaire les visages de ces gens ont
beaucoup changé
c'est des gens je pense qu'ils
s'imaginaient pas du tout avoir recours
en comptoir alimentaire
mais quand la pandémie a frappé son
retrouver sans revenu puis son talent au
comptoir alimentaire
ouais exactement des travailleurs sans
aucun doute qu'ils ont perdu leur emploi
on va regarder quelques-unes allez-y
nommé son soulier juste avant la
pandémie le problème du québec c'est
qu'ils avaient trop d'emplois par ces
deux travailleurs donc je pense que les
gens doutent ou s'imaginait être en
perte d'emploi dépend des revenus du
gouvernement puis cdc des gens dans son
nom ce qu'on a vu c'est qu'il n'y avait
jamais eu recours au chômage de leur vie
avait toujours travaillé puis se
retrouver du jour au lendemain sans
capables d'assurer la sécurité
alimentaire de la famille absolument
beaucoup de gens ont frappé un mur avec
cet arrêt on va regarder trois questions
de votre de votre enquête c'est assez
intéressant dans quelle mesure seriez
vous à l'aise de dire à vos proches que
vous avez eu recours à un comptoir des
aides alimentaires très à l'aise assez à
l'aise il y en a un peu mais pas
beaucoup c'est surtout des gens peu à
l'aise pas à l'aise du tout de dire ça
une forme de de honte pourrait-on dire
monsieur river où elle cessa de jusqu'au
social de stigmatisation ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que dans nos questions
de ce sondage on disait les gens étaient
d'accord que aujourd'hui c'est pas juste
les gens les plus défavorisés
recours des comptes hors d'elle ça peut
être à peu près n'importe qui donc cette
idée de fête chemin est acceptée par
contre pour soi même y aller il n'y a eu
encore une jeune disco sociale puis même
on a demandé spécifiquement aux gens qui
ont eu recours qu'on observe les mêmes
résultats laissent une majorité qui est
pas à l'aise
ouais d'ailleurs je me rappelle que le
premier ministre le go au début de la
crise en quand ça a commencé vraiment la
crise et le chômage et la fermeture il
avait dit n'ayez pas honte d'aller
demander de l'aide alimentaire savez
choqué un peu les gens là de l'entendre
dire ça mais la réalité c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui tout à coup se sont
retrouvés obligés à aller faire une
demande à une banque alimentaire
c'est ça que je pense que booster
beaucoup c'était beaucoup les autres
aspects pour les autres et banque
alimentaire mais que d'un coup ils sont
trouvés c'était pour hull puis dans le
sondage souvent on surestime un peu les
choses qui sont désirables socialement
qui ont sont sous-estiment des choses
sont stigmatisés comme par exemple les
loteries vidéo on on sait qu'on s'est
beaucoup plus beau dans moi je trouve
que le chiffre de 650 milles qu'on ne
trouve il est sûrement conservateur ah
oui et pas vraiment plus de gens que sa
maîtresse et 650 milles qui nous ont
avoué le web donc que l'on dit c'est ça
faut le dire faux pas ok on va regarder
une autre question de votre de votre
enquête si vous ne trouvez pas un emploi
lorsque la pcu assurance emploi se
terminera pendant combien de temps
pourrait vous assurer une alimentation
adéquate à vous et à votre famille avant
d'avoir recours à un comptoir des aides
alimentaires 10,8 pour cent 10 4
semaines au moins 35 % 5 semaines et
plus donc il ya quand même ça va venir
rapidement à la fin des soutiens
gouvernementaux beaucoup de gens
pourraient tout à coup devoir se tourner
vers la banque alimentaire se soit puis
l'autre chiffre qui est très grands là
dedans c'est 46 % qu'ils disent je ne
sais pas donc dans le fond c'est qu'il
ya juste 35 pour ça qu'ils ont une
espèce de plans de contingence pour un
mois mais tout le reste c'est soit
qu'ils savent que ils vont arriver
rapidement au bout de leurs vivres où
ils n'ont juste pas de plein le ccce on
va voir mais on va voir les repas 36
solutions
ouais c'est très intéressant puis on va
regarder une dernière
question de votre enquête si vous deviez
faire face à une dépense imprévue de 500
$ que feriez-vous 50 % disent je
recourait à mes économies 22%
j'utiliserai mon crédit avec une
institution financière et 5% genre
présenterait à la famille ou à des
connaissances et 4 pour ça je rendrai
des biens c'est ce qui a fait les gens
aussi qui disait je ne sais pas mais
mais c'est que c'est à près de la moitié
des gens qui on compte 5 500 dollars
donc 500 $ de vous traîtres et à tokyo
vous savez comme moi que c'est une
petite réparation sur une voiture c'est
à peine frigidaire sa peine de l'areuse
donc les gens sont très serrés puis
c'est comparable des mesures qu'on avait
pris dans leur poser des questions 2017
ça ressemblait beaucoup mais on reste l
ancien monde où toute façon il y avait
de l'emploi va se trouver
c'était comme facile de l'économie
roulait bien ça fait longtemps qu'on
oppose fait face à une récession dans le
fond en quelqu'un qui a 40 45 ans a
jamais vraiment eu une vraie récession
donc les choses ont changé ville
je pense qu'on va falloir que les gens
adhap la leurs revenus et leurs dépenses
en fonction des trains en tout cas vos
données frappe l'imaginaire merci
beaucoup monsieur rivet pour ces
informations 16 heures
merci